チビが持てる世界の実現を小学校とかは
ドッジボール強かったらモテると思います
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです今回も
3億円の豪邸です
すごい人だった戦いますこちらの方です
どうぞ
お願いしまーすお願いしますお願いします
何やらボールを持ってますね皆様なんです
か2019年マルチドッジボール日本代表
今後の部キャプテンの篠原先生です
よろしくお願いしますよろしくお願いし
ます日本代表日本代表です
2019年日本代表中村浩司ですエース
アタッカーをやらさせていただいており
ますか
[音楽]
ありがとうございました2019年どっち
終わり日本代表の吉田俊哉です吉田さん
よろしくお願いします42歳です42歳
お三方は
ドッジボール日本代表ということで
キャプテンとエースと今日はあのベテラン
レジェンドでありがとうございます
私やってみたいことがありまして
ボール王に
ボールをどっちにとります
ボールを使った鬼ごっこですねこの家で
ドッジボール日本最強の皆さんとだったら
いい試合出来るんじゃないかなと思いまし
てみなさんもちょっと上手いじゃないです
かこのドッジボールのプロとして
めちゃくちゃもうこの家のことは
僕の方が知ってるんですよ僕も動画で見て
きました
待ってください見ちゃったんですか
鬼ごっこというか3億円の家全体で使った
ドッジボールをしたいなと思っております
普通のコートではなく庭を動いたり移動し
たり走ったりするんで
ワンチャンいい勝負できないかと思って
今回皆さんお呼びさせていただきましたと
いうわけで今回3対3でやらせていただき
たいと思ってこちらもメンバーを準備して
おります
全然違いました今回3対3でやりたいなと
思いますこちらもメンバー2人
追加で準備してますどうぞ
全くやったことないです
管理人なら家のこと
家のことは一番知ってるの
はいそして
ドッジボール歴
ボールにどっちボールデッキは
実は3年ぐらい
同じやつやってましたこのボールをこの
血のりもあるのでかなり戦力だろう最強
じゃないかお前
これはね
勝ちました
多分なんですけど
僕はのフルメンバーこんな感じ
にドッツボール経験者で今回参拝さんで
戦えればなと思ってますよろしくお願いし
ますよろしくお願いします
ルール説明させてくださいサバイバル
ドッジボールみたいな感じになると思い
ます
場所は3億円の
全部です外壁はなしにしましょうボール
飛んでいくと危ないので
壁の中なら全部で3対3で5対ここでやり
ますとでボールは1個です例えば階段登っ
てるところを挟み撃ちしてボールパスして
詰めるとかそういうパスを使って倒すって
いう戦略もありかなとで1人2機です合計
でみんなロッキー6ストックあって2回
当たったらアウトで退場した人は
僕らも2機もらっていいんですか
これちょっと特殊なんですけども誰かが
投げて味方キャッチしたら
0基の仲間が一気復活しますなので復活し
ても一気なんですけどももうゾンビのよう
に戦えるという作戦もキャッチできるとで
敵への接触は禁止です直接的なあの2人で
1人をこうなんかしてるんで
それちょっともうずるというか
ラストさせていただきます
制限時間は30分ですで30分後になって
お互いに人が残っていたら残った規制が
多いチームが勝ちですこのまま30分何事
もなく終わったら我々の勝手ですね
意図的に隠れ続けるのやめましょうはいで
頭と金的なセーフですというルールで30
分が3対3でよろしくお願いします
では戦っていきましょう
俺のパン見せていい
俺当たらないけどパワーはあるタイプだっ
たよ
投げ方癖強い投げるの下手なんだけど
避けるのはちょっとね
生き残るタイプだ
えなんで
避けるの得意でなんで投げた今投げるのが
得意じゃなくてキャッチが得意な人です
ばらついかもね
作戦は
隠れてていいと思う
から
見つけたら1人で行ってもまず無理です
俺たちボールじゃなくて意味ないの
先行されなかったら一気無駄にしようそう
だね
マイボールから始めよう
ね
しました
[音楽]
[拍手]
作戦的にボール持ってる時56mずつ間隔
あてながら
ピンポイントでパンパンパンって当てる
ような感じ
というわけでボーリングアップが終わった
ので早速試合していきたいと思います
というわけで
先行高校じゃんけんの決めましょう
[音楽]
1分ごとお願いします
[拍手]
もう
投げていいかな最初に寝ろ
[音楽]
無駄にしてもいいはいマイボールにする
ことが大事だはい行きまーす
[音楽]
行きましょう
あれ
来ないね
[拍手]
全身ビリビリでしたよ
[音楽]
[拍手]
しこっからです
行くぞ
よく
[拍手]
わかったらこれで
OK
[音楽]
下に2人上に1人
こっちもいるぞー
これ
[音楽]
ボールを隠して
[拍手]
[音楽]
頑張って当てて戻したけど
動画的にキャッチして
キュート
[音楽]
呼び込みましょう逆にワンワン
先行きましょうもうこれは
[音楽]
[拍手]
風はまだだよまだだ
2人倒せばいいんだね
時間
[音楽]
[笑い]
的に言うと9分ぐらいですね
9分持ったお疲れ様でした
もう1回いいですか
[音楽]
もう少し楽しみたいですね
もう1回お願いします
先行高校は
[音楽]
お願いします最初はグーじゃんけんぽい
いやー
じゃあ1分後に
正直何が犯人か
[音楽]
な
取れちゃうっていう仕組みですねなるほど
ねそうなると後ろで挟んでパソコン
全員これで移動して
視聴者の皆さん誰が持ってるでしょうか
いきます
見られてました
[拍手]
2階の広い
どうしました
[音楽]
わかんの何ですか
ずっと
[音楽]
それっぽい連携になってきてるけど
うまい
[音楽]
[拍手]
OKOK
門松されてていなくてこういった瞬間そこ
に目があって
俺たちと5気あるよね
[音楽]
疲れるぜこれ
頑張れー
[音楽]
[拍手]
俺見てたけど行けなかった
怖くて今何期ですか
5期
お前ら難しい約束したの
キャッチで全員復活で逆襲でいきますお
願いします
あと4気かまず一発かわしてきます
あんたが英雄だ
タイヤこっち行った
[音楽]
[拍手]
待っててください
[音楽]
待ってください
[拍手]
[音楽]
上から見ててもう終わっただと
あとじゃあ3期待期か
待たせた
慎重に行こう
頑張れ
なるほど
[拍手]
ですかここにあと2機の男が最初
芽生えるの俺は
対決
[音楽]
[拍手]
お疲れ様でした
一対一ということでどうでした今日普段の
ドッジボールと結構違うと思うんですけど
全く
違いますこんなにあの汗かくと思う
勝てるかなって思ってたところ最後ずっと
追われてる感覚があったんで
血のりをめちゃめちゃコースター
上からやられたあれは僕らなかなかでき
ないまたぜひリベンジしましょう
よろしくお願いしますありがとうござい
ました